[Musique]
sur l'augmentation de la passion pour
les aînés la bataille devra continuer
devra continuer parce que non seulement
ça n'a pas été fait mais de surcroît le
gouvernement trudeau a créé une
inacceptable discrimination
le chef du bloc québécois dénonce les
actions du gouvernement trudeau qui a
créé selon lui deux classes d'aînés les
personnes de 75 ans et plus vont
recevoir un paiement spécial de 500
dollars cette semaine et leur pension
sera bonifié de 10% l'an prochain les
aînés de 65 à 74 ans n'auront pas un sou
de plus le bloc demandent une
augmentation de la pension de 110
dollars par mois indexable pour tous les
aînés de 65 ans avec nous ce soir le
fiscaliste luc godbout bonsoir luc au
noir parlons donc du design est un
plaisir d'abord de vous retrouver puis
on va sans doute vous retrouver à
quelques reprises durant la campagne est
ce que est ce que les
65-74 ans sont désavantagés par les
mesures du gouvernement trudeau sont
oubliés
je dirais que non ils sont désavantagés
par rapport aux acquis par rapport à
quoi
c'est sûr que si on regarde par rapport
aux années de 75 ans et plus qui eurent
ou une bonification on peut dire que les
aînés de 65 à 74 ans
on peut on pas eu le même avantage mais
des aînés de 65 à 74 ans ont rien plus
rien moins que leurs régimes qui
existait avant les élections de 2010
neuf donc ils sont pas perdre dans leurs
régimes ont été indexés alors sont plus
en situation ait changé
cela dit avec la pandémie lyon rue des
petits programmes les aînés de 65 à 74
ans il ya une bonification il ya un an
juillet 2020 psv de 300 dollars
le supplément de revenu garanti sans
paiement ponctuel est également bonifié
il ya une bonification général de la tps
pour l'année 2020 dont les aînés ont
profité mais mais seuls dix
effectivement ils n'ont pas eu droit à
une bonification de la pension de
sécurité de la vieillesse comme les 61
ans et plus et donc les 75 ans et plus
vont recevoir ou ont déjà reçu cheikh un
paiement dans leurs comptes cette
semaine de 500 $ parlez nous de ce
paiement de 500 $ qui rappelons le est
imposable oui c'est un paiement de 500 $
qui est imposable il est versé au mois
d'août belle quoi belle synchronisation
avec le déclenchement des élections dont
neuf semaines il est versé on dit qu'on
vise les aînés de 75 ans et plus mais
comme gerald vous êtes bons en calcul
mental toute personne de né le 30 juin
2009 147 ou avant donc des personnes
comptent 74 ans en autant qu'ils aient à
75 ans en juin 2022 il est qu'ils soient
admissibles actuellement la pension ont
droit à cette bonification de 500 $
imposable mais le véritable programme
que le parti libéral au fait où le
gouvernement libéral a fait c'est la
promesse qu'ils avaient engagé en l'an
2019 qui était de bonifier de 10% la
pension de sécurité de la vieillesse
pour les 75 ans et plus et ça c'est ce
qu'ils font à partir de juillet 2022
autre élément qui est important c'est
sur le supplément de revenu garanti
on a constaté que les aînés qui ont
touché la prestation canadienne
d'urgence constate cet été que leur
supplément de revenu garanti a pu être
amputés
expliquez-nous un peu cette situation
ils ont raison d'ailleurs donc ce qu'il
faut bien comprendre c'est la bande à la
pcu ou la pca eyrolles la prestation
canadienne de relance économique ou
d'anciens ou seulement ça est là ont pas
le même effet que le revenu de travail
dans la détermination du léman de revenu
garanti donc je vous donne un exemple on
va prendre un et des célibataires
qui avait pour l'année 2020 une pension
de sécurité de la vieillesse dans
environ 7400 $ un régime des rentes du
québec de 5000 $ et qui a traversé
quelques uns pour permission d'en point
année qui aurait pas besoin d'avoir
gagné dix mille de revenus du travail
exemple fictif cas pour une paix ces
unités ses erreurs lorsqu'on va arriver
le moment de calculer combien vous avez
droit pour 2021 à partir de juillet
veille de 2021 le supplément de revenus
annuels on vient vous avez droit on va
dire vous avez droit à 6000 annuellement
suis la même personne dans la même
situation que lui la même passion de
sécurité de la vieillesse ne même régime
des rentes mais qu' il ya perdu son ton
revenu de travail à cause de la pandémie
en mars 2020 et seulement 2000 de
revenus de travail et qu'on le compenser
pour un montant de 8000 donc dans les
faits il ya pas plus d'argent dans ses
poches là mais là qu'on va arriver pour
calculer sa détention admissibilité au
supplément de revenu garanti comme le
revenu de travail ad et tribus
facilitant quand on détermine le
supplément de revenu garanti
on n'en considèrent qu'une partie donc
si vous gagnez 10 m de revenus de
travail on va considérer au fait
supplément de revenu garanti
le premier 5000 on ne calcule pas qu on
calcule 50 soudan le dollar ou le 5000
suivant donc on va dire vous avez juste
dernier 2500 de revenus de travail n'est
que vous allez gagner dix mille on
arrive à pc urbain vous avez gagné 8
milles on considère rumine il est donc
cette personne-là pas voir au lieu
d'avoir six mille de supplément de
revenu garanti aurez droit 2902
supplément de revenu garanti donc tout
un changement qui est quand même
est important donc le fait d'avoir perdu
son emploi cette année qui a perdu son
emploi perd son avantage fiscal qui
étaient ceux ci au fait de travailler
les mêmes charges y emmène dolan et cela
est donc ça affecte davantage son
supplément de revenu garanti d'un même
dollars gagnés suprême de pcu plutôt que
se forme de revenus de travail ok on
corrige pas comment le godbout bain ou
encore i show commence si on veut le
chaos objets comme c'est assez
ponctuelle on pourrait dire que tous les
programmes d'assurance salaire que ce
soit l'assurance emploi la pcu la pcr
eux si on les considérait au fait de la
détermination du supplément de revenu
garanti comme des revenus de travail ou
des revenus d'emploi et l'autre tout le
monde soit traité également ça dans leur
contexte ça coûte combien je l'ait pas
calculer ok alors ce sera pour la
prochaine entrevue merci beaucoup le
goût de boost est très intelligent il va
devoir revoir pour voir nos émissions en
entier rendez vous sur la chaîne i cirdi